IDO GREEN: So hello, and welcome
to another episode of
GDL-IL, GDL Israel.
Today we're going to speak about
Google APIs, how easy is
it to work with them and consume
them, both from the
client and the server.
We have a few examples that show
you the power of working
with Google APIs, with
JavaScript, of course, on the
client side.
And then on the server side, I
choose to show some simple
examples in PHP because it's the
recent addition to Google
App Engine.
So I guess people will want
to see how to leverage.
So today we don't
have any slides.
We just have some codes.
And let me share with you my
screen so we'll be able to
flip quickly between the browser
and the text editor.
So let's make this one, and
let's see first how we're
going to tackle it.
So we'll start on
the server side.
And to start on the server side,
basically you need to go
and download the library that
enable your encapsulating for
you of all the rich
functionality that you have in
Google APIs.
It's one line, and as you can
see here, you just need to
copy this one--
it's curl--
and get it.
Once you get it, actually if
you click on this link, it
will download it for
you immediately.
You unzip it, of course, tar it,
and then you have a quite
nice set of examples that's
showing you the power of
different APIs that you could
leverage out of the vast
enormous richness of different
APIs that Google
allows you to consume.
Another important note
is the console.
So on the console--
let's go here to the GDL
example that I started.
When you're just starting with
the console, you basically
need to create yourself an
OAuth 2.0 client ID.
And you need to do it because
lots of Google services and I
guess if you will create with
Google Cloud Endpoint service
for you, you'll want to make
sure that it's authenticated.
And the easiest way to do is
just come here, to click on
the OAuth 2.0 button, give
your product a name.
In our case, it will
be [AUDIO OUT].
And you probably will want to
give here some sort of a logo,
a nice one, and Page
URL [AUDIO OUT]
all the projects, and then
we're clicking yes.
You could choose if it's going
to be a web application or a
service, where basically
you'll want for your
application to make the calls,
or an installed application.
So for native apps in Android
and iOS or on Windows, Linux,
or Mac, you'll probably want
to choose this option.
In our option, let's stick
with web application, but
please remember that you could
also get it as a service, and
then basically you don't need
any other information.
If you're going with web
application, one of the
important things is that you
need to enter your endpoint of
your application.
And in our case just to make
things [AUDIO OUT], let's keep
with the local host.
And then you'll have the
redirect, of course, that
basically we get the
confirmation after Google has
authenticated your user or
your call and given you a
token to continue.
In my case, you could see that,
quite quickly, set it to
be localauth and
oauthcallback.
And of course, you could edit
those settings and add a few
other redirects URL to other
environments that you have.
So in most of the cases, you'd
probably want to put the QI
environment, maybe the
staging environment.
And then hopefully, on
production, you won't use the
same keys, You will
create a new one.
After we created this, we're
going with services.
And for the services, you have
here a huge richness of
different services that
you could [INAUDIBLE].
Some of them are completely
free.
Some of them are with just a
bit of payment per usage.
But it's all very detailed right
here in the console.
And you could see quite quickly
how many you have
active, how many you
have inactive.
And just to show you how you
play with it, so let's say
that I want to work with--
I don't know-- the
calendar API.
So I'll activate it.
Of course, I need to confirm
the term of service.
And once I am accepting it,
I have here now one active
service that I could run on
this specific service.
Now, if I want to start and see
what I could do with this
service, there's a nice
question mark here.
And If I'll click and try it
out, immediately I'm being
redirected, and I can start
and see what this API is
exposing to me.
So this is part basically
of the discovery
mechanism that we have.
And if you remember during my
talk in the last I/O, we spoke
about Cloud Endpoint and how you
could leverage this system
in creating your own API and
enjoying this discovery
mechanism to make your
work more productive.
So after we do all this,
basically we have a few other
things that we could run with.
Here you have a very nice page
that's letting you check which
services you authorized.
And once you're working with
development, you might want to
revoke access to some of the
services so you could tests
again and again the
authentication phase and make
sure that you're doing
the right things.
If you want to play with a
certain API, one great way to
work with the API on the web
without coding even one line
is just to go to
developers.google.com and go
here on the API Explorer.
And in our case, I choose the
YouTube data API because this
is the example that
I prepared.
And here you can see that--
let's say that I want to get
from YouTube the idea in the
snippet per video.
Then I want the max
results to be--
I don't know--
9.
And the query that I'll
put, it could be
ski, it could be snowboard.
And once I'm executing it, I'm
getting here the response.
I could take basically these
and just play in other
environment on it.
But here you could say
that I got 200, so
everything is cool.
And here I'm getting a nice JSON
object that basically is
describing all the
result sets.
And you could see that I'm
getting the videos.
I'm getting the thumbnails to
the videos, the ID, everything
that I basically requested.
Now, if we look at how this
example looked on PHP, on PHP,
it will be quite similar
in a lot of sense.
So we'll come here, and it might
be a bit crowded, but I
hope that you can see here.
Basically we have a simple page
that's letting us query a
YouTube API.
We want to get from the user a
search term and then probably
to limit the result.
And that's it in the bottom
for the search action.
What I'm fetching here is two
libraries, is two files that
actually are exposing and
encapsulating YouTube service.
So it's first the Google client,
so just I'll have all
the basic functionality and
then the YouTube itself.
Once I'm doing that, I
have here, of course,
the developer key.
And now I'm just calling the
constructor of Google Client
and working with it.
So I'm setting the developer
key, and I'm calling with this
client to YouTube service.
After I do this exactly like I
showed you in the Explorer
API, I'm basically calling
YouTube Search searchlist.
And you can see here in the
Explorer API, that it's
exactly the same endpoint.
So this one is exactly
like this one.
And again, very similar to what
we did in the example on
the API Explorer, I'm going, and
I'm concentrating on the
idea in the snippet.
I want to pass the query and, of
course, the max results, so
this is my payload.
And now all I'm doing is going
on this nice loop and making
sure that the result set-- which
is basically separated
into three buckets.
One is the videos and the
channels and then the playlist
we'll bring back.
And in my body, I will just
make sure that I'm
constructing those lists.
So I'm using the ul and
the ly tags just to
construct it in here.
Very simple.
I just embedded it here,
and that's it.
Let's look how it's working
on my local environment.
So let's close now with
the Dev tool.
We'll look at it later.
So if I'm searching for--
I don't know.
I'm limiting it to 10 results.
When I'm clicking search,
basically it's going to
YouTube, returning.
And as you can see here,
basically I just added the
image as well.
So unlike the previous example,
we're getting more
holistic search results, if you
will, so it's a bit more
informative.
Exactly like you saw before it
here on the API Explorer, I'm
just fetching that elements from
the result sets and just
presenting them on
the page itself.
Now, as you all know, we have
a bunch of client libraries
that are actually letting you
leverage Google APIs.
On the web, you might use the
JavaScript library, and I'll
show you in a minute an example
how easy and smooth it
is to work with.
But if you're working with
JavaScript on the server side,
we have a nice library for
Node.js, so please feel free
to check it out.
By the way, all the
links are here.
So if you'll go to
pictures-app.appspot.com,
you'll be able to look at the
slides that are from that
previous I/O talk, but also,
on slide 25, as you can see
here, all the links for all the
different libraries and
languages that you
could leverage.
So for the ones that are
building native clients, both
for iOS and Android, we
have nice libraries.
And of course, on the
server side, you
have a bunch of languages.
And actually we have even for
.NET and GWT and many others.
So let's close that and see
how we could run an
authentication.
So in this specific example,
let's first look at a code,
and then we'll look
at a live example.
I want to authenticate
myself and get some
information from G+.
In our case, probably it will
be the image and the email.
But as you can imagine, you
could run and do a lot of more
things once you get the token,
the handle of your user.
This is a very short example,
and as always in JavaScript,
let's jump to the end.
And first and foremost, we're
calling Google client library,
the JavaScript client library.
And we're going to get
here a callback.
So on load, we'll handle
basically the callback and see
what we're doing.
So we're setting, of course,
the client ID and some
boilerplate data like the
API key and the scope.
And then when we're
coming here to
handle the client load.
We're setting those API keys,
and we just want to call
immediately the check
authentication, so we did it
with set timeout.
After we're doing it, we're
just going to GAPI--
Google API.
And this endpoint on the
authentication we want to authorize.
The authorize will be done with
the client ID, the scope.
And of course, we want
to do it immediately.
And then we're giving it another
callback to just
handle the result set that
we're getting back.
In our case, it's this one.
And when we're getting the
authentication, we want to do
several things.
So first, if everything is OK
and we don't have any error,
let's just go here and hide the
Authorize button so the
user won't be confused.
And in a real world case, you
might want at this stage to
make sure that you're confirming
and you're showing
the user that he or
she are logged in.
It might be through a nice
image of the cells or any
other nice bold way to show that
they are now logged in
and authenticated.
And now we're making
the API call.
Of course, on the opposite
direction, we do want to make
sure that the button is visible,
like you've seen
here, so people could authorize
themselves and log
in or sign in to our app.
Once we are handling the
authentication, we want
basically to make
the API call.
We're going to G+ API.
We're controlling the version.
So in our case here,
it would be d1.
And basically what I want to
fetch from people is just me.
And I'm taking the image of
myself and just putting it on
the page itself.
Now let's work on the live
example and see how it does.
So as you can see here, I'm
being authenticated so it's
immediately popping up the
request for permission dialog.
In this case, you could see
that I used the Chrome
extension book examples, just
because I have it handy.
And hopefully in the near
future, you'll be able to see
some live relevant examples
to Chrome extensions.
But I'm allowing access, and
then basically I've been
redirected again to this page.
And as you can see, I have now
my photo and my title here.
So this is one example that's
showing you the power
[INAUDIBLE].
And now let's see another
simple example
that's showing you.
So I have here another page,
which is basically the
[INAUDIBLE] or the sample that
you're getting with Google API
PHP client examples.
And here basically we'll do
exactly the same, but instead
of JavaScript, we'll
just leverage PHP.
So I'm going to the directory
of the example, UserInfo.
And after I log out, before the
session, of course, I want
now to authenticate myself.
So again I'll get this nice
authorization dialog.
And after I'm doing it, and as
you can see here it was in
Hebrew, I'm getting again in
this case my email and photo.
How would the code look like?
Let's jump real quick
and let's remove
this one for a second.
Yeah, so here, yeah.
So again I'm calling the Google
OAuth 2.0 service.
And after we're setting the
Google client and giving it a
bunch of IDs-- and by the way,
the client ID, the developer
key and everything else could
be found here on your API
access tab.
So if you'll click on it,
basically all the relevant
information that you need to
copy/paste, like the client
ID, the client secret, and the
API key, are all here.
So just remember API's console,
and this is the location.
So once you're doing that,
basically we're calling the
OAuth service with our client.
And we are pressing the code,
and we want to fetch token.
The token is something that
we'll carry with us so we'll
be able to confirm again and
again if we need to the
service itself.
And since in this case already
at the beginning if we're
getting the token here, then
we just need to go do the
redirect, and we're all good.
If not, we want to set the
token, make sure that if the
user is clicking on log
out, we're, of course,
revoking the token.
And here we're just calling
the client, and we want to
fetch the token.
So after we're getting it and
this is returning as true
because we have the token in
the client, we're basically
going to the OAuth service.
And with the user info object,
we want to get the
information.
And as you saw in my case, it
was-- in the PHP case, it was
the email and the picture,
the profile picture.
And what we did with this is
just we put it on the page so
we'd be able to see it.
Here, last but not least, we, of
course, want to save in our
SessionToken or any other place
that you find convenient
and safe for your app, the token
itself, so you will able
to leverage it and use it
later on in your app.
And this is all we have here.
So the bit HTML that we have
later on is just to make sure
that we have those two cases of
connect, or logged in, and
the logged out.
So this, I guess,
was a very short
introduction to Google APIs.
Next week or in the near future,
I'll try to show you
how you could leverage those
type of APIs when competing
for your services.
And that's with Google Could
Endpoint basically taking
those APIs that we're using
internally and just expose
them to the developer.
So if you want to leverage
Google App Engine and create a
powerful scalable API on top of
it, you might want to use
Google Cloud Endpoint.
And then you're benefiting and
getting for free all the great
capabilities of the discovery
mechanism, the API Explorer,
and all the richness of
libraries that are
all ready for you.
We'll speak about it hopefully
next week and, if not, in the
near future.
And now is a great time for
questions if someone that
joined us have, please
feel free.
OK, so later on, if someone have
any questions, just feel
free to reach me on
plus.google.com/plusgreenido--
one word.
And until next week, have a
great time and bye-bye.